su
madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer un plan pour
relancer les véhicules propres en france
il pourrait être en partie financée par
une augmentation du prix du diesel pour
les particuliers neige c'est non en
suédois non à l'euro à une très large
majorité
nous tenterons de voir quelles sont les
conséquences de ce refus pour l'europe
avec nos envoyés spéciaux
enfin le dossier de la rédaction ça tape
sur le sort de ces deux cent trente
ouvriers indiens qui se retrouvent sans
travail à saint nazaire
ils participaient à la construction du
queen mary 2 et le contrat de leur
société a été dénoncé les automobilistes
risquent de faire grise mine le
gouvernement envisage en effet de
surtaxer le diesel à partir de janvier
prochain